[Applause]  four on the shot clock marathon drive  morant  jones just gets it off the time it's  good  just  john morant over handling but he gets  rid of it  and just in the nick of time jones  [Applause]  shot clock at seven  morant finds clark clark inside the pass  to jackson lays it up and in  40 to 22 to score here in this fourth  quarter edward's a three-pointer that  won't go and that'll do it the grizzlies  do it again  [Applause]  and they move into the second round for  the first time in seven years  as minnesota suffers another  heartbreaking loss in what otherwise was  a terrific season for these young  timberwolves  [Applause]  and this fun entertaining series  comes to an end  you can see the anguish with anthony  edwards  what a talented young